einigung auf weitere öffnung spielplatz
und gottesdienst besucher können unter
auflagen wieder möglich sein
das und mehr wollen bund und länder
hoffnung auf schnellere heilung eine
studie aus den usa zeigt positive
ergebnisse wenn patienten mit einem
ebola medikament behandelt werden
unruhe wegen geplante ablösung die spd
will einen neuen wehrbeauftragten des
bundestags und provoziert damit streit
in den eigenen reihen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und herzlich
willkommen bei den nachrichten an diesem
april einem datum dass wir im kopf haben
weil die bundeskanzlerin heute mit den
ministerpräsidenten der länder beraten
wollte wie es weitergeht in der korona
krise und weil wohl viele auf weitere
lockerungen hofften waren die
erwartungen hoch
vor knapp zwei stunden hat die kanzlerin
die pläne vorgestellt
demnach steht es den ländern frei etwa
spielplätze wieder zu öffnen oder
kirchen und gebetshäuser und auch zoos
und museen können wieder besucht werden
alles unter strengen hygiene auflagen
einzelheiten jetzt von thomas reichert
ein paar kam tatsächlich selbst ins
kanzleramt
die meisten länder chefs aber sind per
video zugeschaltet bei der
entscheidenden frage wieviel kroner
lockerung die politik wagen will trotz
sinkender infektionszahlen mahnt merkel
zur vorsicht immer wieder haben wir die
große verantwortung
alles was wir in unserer macht haben zu
tun damit es keinen rückfall in eine
schwierigere phase gibt sondern dass wir
schritt für schritt vorankommen
immerhin darauf einigen sich bund und
länder zoos museen und ausstellungen
können unter auflagen wieder öffnen
auch gottesdienste sollen wieder
stattfinden kinder dürfen wieder auf die
spielplätze einige länder haben schon
gleich verkündet dass sie das sofort
umsetzen wollen
über die öffnung von kitas und schulen
wollen bund und länder erst in der
nächsten woche entscheiden ist auch
wichtig dass man die zeitachse so
definiert dass wir nicht chaos und den
schulen haben und wieder zurück drehen
müssen also schulen schließen sind
obwohl sie gerade eröffnet haben freie
fahrt also gibt es noch nicht er ein
vorsichtiges herantasten für die
opposition sind das kleine aber nicht
die entscheidenden schritte hotels und
gaststätten brauchen eine klare ansage
wann sie wieder unter einhaltung von
wegen aufmachen können bei den schul
öffnungen hätte ich mir mehr erwartet
mehr sicherheit für schülerinnen und
schüler und natürlich auch für
lehrerinnen und lehrer und die eltern
das was wir jetzt haben ist wieder ein
aufschub
doch über weitere lockerungen oder eine
stadt der bundesliga wollen bund und
länder frühestens bei der nächsten
konferenz in der kommenden woche
entscheiden
die pressekonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin ist er mit spannung
erwartet worden
jacques und energy aber bei den
genannten lockerungen fehlte ja eben
doch entscheidendes wie etwa kitas und
schulen wie wir gerade gehörten warum
ist man da noch zurückhaltend da muss
wohl sagen aus sorge vor einem rückfall
durch weitere lockerungen momentan
scheint man den eindruck zu haben dass
die situation so wie sie jetzt ist ganz
gut unter kontrolle ist die
infektionszahlen sind vertretbar es gibt
genug intensivbetten man hat auch die
infektionsketten einigermaßen im blick
und damit kann man sozusagen arbeiten
ohne die das gefühl zu haben dass die
pandemie hier aus dem ruder läuft im
nächsten schritt herrscht eben denn die
sorge wenn man weitere öffnungen macht
dass man dass diese kontrolle dann eben
wieder verliert und dass die zahlen sich
dann sehr sehr schnell multiplizieren
das gilt vor allem für orte an denen
menschen schnell in großen mengen auf
einen raum kommen deswegen gibt es neben
schulen und kitas auch ganze bereiche
die eben noch sehr viel länger als
erwartet warten müssen nämlich die
gastronomie die kultur aber auch der
tourismus dafür sollen bund und ländern
nicht nächste woche beraten sondern erst
bei der sitzung darauf die ist dann zwei
wochen nach dem 6
also in der zweiten maihälfte dass es
noch eine relativ lange durststrecke die
opposition sagt da muss noch mehr kommen
in den nächsten wochen aber die regieren
im bund und ländern setzen eben momentan
lieber auf vorsicht da heißt es geduld
haben vielen dank und was wann gelockert
wird dazu gibt es ein zdf spezial gleich
im anschluss an diese sendung mit fragen
an markus söder und armin laschet und
für noch mehr informationen und grafiken
empfehlen wir ihnen unsere zdf heute app
dort finden sie auch einen live blog
der lange schatten in der krise hat
gravierende folgen für die wirtschaft es
drohe die schwerste rezession der
nachkriegsgeschichte so die
frühjahrsprognose der bundesregierung
gestern heute liefert die bundesagentur
für arbeit ihre zahlen zur lage und sie
sind nicht weniger dramatisch
arbeitslosigkeit und vor allem
kurzarbeit steigen in vor kurzem noch
nicht für möglich gehaltene höhen
thomas konzern viel gewalt keine gäste
restaurants bleiben leer hotels
ebenfalls wo keine kunden sind wird auch
kaum personal gebraucht inhaber schicken
mitarbeiter nach hause
corona zeit heißt kurzarbeit diese
maßnahme haben deutschlands unternehmen
bis zum sonntag für 10,1 millionen
menschen angemeldet noch mehr als
befürchtet und mehr als in der
finanzkrise da gab es 3,3 millionen
anmeldungen
seither konnte ein bundesarbeitsminister
vor der presse er positives verkünden
nun also einen negativrekord zugleich
beruhigende worte
kurzarbeit ist unser stärkstes
instrument gegen entlassungen
es schützt millionen von menschen man
musste internationalen vergleich eher
erwähnen in den letzten fünf monaten
sind in den vereinigten staaten von
amerika 26 millionen jobs verschwunden
in deutschland werden millionen von
arbeitsplätze durch kurzarbeit gesichert
dennoch ist auch die zahl der
arbeitslosen corona bedingt gestiegen
im april waren zwei millionen 644.000
menschen ohne job 308.000 mehr als im
märz die quote legte liegt nun bei 5,8
prozent normalerweise sinken die zahlen
denn besseres wetter heißt bessere
jobaussichten und nun es wird nicht viel
schlimmer sagt die bundesagentur für
arbeit jedenfalls beim niveau der
kurzarbeit
es wird leicht steigen aber werden nicht
mehr die situation erleben
wo wir auf einmal zu wechsel von 100.000
haben davon gehen wir nicht aus also ich
würde sagen ja wir haben die spitze
erreicht kurzarbeit rekord jeder dritte
arbeitnehmer bedroht so lautet sie die
nachricht zum ersten mai dem tag der
arbeit auch viele studentinnen und
studenten stehen seitdem corona ausbruch
plötzlich ohne job da damit sie ihre
ausbildung trotzdem weiter finanzieren
können hat die bundesregierung
notkredite beschlossen die staatliche
förderbank kfw vergibt die zinslosen
darlehen über monatlich bis zu 650 euro
ab dem 8 mai den antrag soll es online
geben
eineinhalb bis knapp zwei jahre nach der
letzten rate müssen die studierenden
dann anfangen das geld zurückzuzahlen
und jetzt der tägliche blick auf die
aktuellen zahlen der chef des robert
koch instituts hat heute noch einmal
bekräftigt dass deutschland nach wie vor
am anfang eines marathons zur
überwindung der krise stehen marcus
thätner berichtet wenn sich der chef des
robert koch instituts in diesen tagen
äußert hat er meist beides im gepäck
gute nachrichten und mahnungen
eine gute nachricht kommt aus den
laboren die test kapazitäten liegen dort
so hoch wie nie 860.000 standen letzte
woche zur verfügung davon wurden 467.000
genutzt ich sehe es als eine positive
entwicklungen
wir testen früher wir finden früher
personen die infizierte und das ist
wirklich von überragender wichtigkeit
wenn wir jetzt diese lockerung
durchführen um das geschehen zu
kontrollieren test kapazität und
ergebnisse sind von überragender
wichtigkeit
und noch eine gute nachricht die
reproduktions zahl liegt bei 0,76 das
heißt jeder infizierte steckt
statistisch weniger als einen menschen
an
doch auf der anderen seite die deutliche
warnung angesichts der lockerungen das
virus nicht zu unterschätzen
dieses virus hat eine reihe von
eigenschaften die ich niemandem
aussetzen möchte weder mir selber und
auch nicht meinen kindern um das ganz
deutlich zu sagen und wer das tut und
denkt dass er damit eine herde
bonität hervorruft ist naiv und auch das
mahnt die zahlen die seit anfang des
monats runtergehen sind wieder leicht
gestiegen
der johns hopkins universität gab es
1600 neue infektionen stand 18 uhr 30
waren demnach in deutschland fast
162.000 corona infizierte durch tests
bestätigt davon gelten mehr als 123.000
als genesen 6504 menschen sind in
verbindung mit dem virus gestorben
weltweit wird nach impfstoffen und
medikamenten gesucht zum hoffnungsträger
könnte rennen sie wir werden
ursprünglich war das mittel gegen das
ebola virus entwickelt worden
jetzt wurde es an 1000 corona patienten
klinisch getestet wissenschaftler in den
usa sprechen von ermutigenden
ergebnissen erkrankte würden damit
schneller gesund doch es gibt auch
skepsis die einzelheiten jetzt von ines
trams der erste wissenschaftliche
berater von präsident trump ein
nüchterner forscher doch die ersten
positiven zahlen dieser
medikamentenstudie will anthony fauci
nicht länger für sich behalten auch wenn
endgültige ergebnisse noch nicht
vorliegen
die daten zeigen remde sie via hat eine
signifikante positive wirkung es
verkürzt die zeit bis zur genesung es
scheint also belegt dass ein medikament
dieses virus aufhalten kann
rem dc wir ein antivirale mittel
ursprünglich entwickelt gegen das
ebola-virus im rahmen einer studie
wurden rund 1000 corona patienten das
medikament intravenös verabreicht im
durchschnitt erholten sich patienten
innerhalb von elf tagen mit rem die sie
wir statt im zuge von 15 tagen nur mit
placebo
die sterblichkeitsrate sinkt allerdings
nur leicht von rund 11 auf 8 prozent
patienten berichten
ungefähr nach der hälfte meines
krankenhausaufenthalts fühlte ich mich
besser ich konnte aufstehen
der potenzielle erfolg des medikaments
ist dennoch weiter umstritten eine
deutlich kleiner angelegte studie in
china mit rund 200 patienten
konnte rim der sie wir keinen nutzen
nachweisen beide studien sind halt
einfach noch nicht groß genug um
wirklich aussagen über die mortalität
also die sterblichkeit durch diese
erkrankung treffen zu können also die
daten für das mdc wir sind interessant
aber sie sind einfach noch unreif
präsident trump drängt jedoch nun darauf
dass rem der sie wir zügig für patienten
verfügbar gemacht wird weltweit ist das
medikament bislang nirgends zugelassen
nach großbritannien dort haben die
behörden die zahl der todesfälle in
verbindung mit dem virus deutlich nach
oben korrigiert und zwar von rund 21.000
auf mehr als 26.000 menschen nur italien
meldet in europa mehr tote
grund für die korrektur bislang zählten
die briten nur die korona toten in
kliniken ab jetzt auch aldi in
pflegeheimen und privathaushalten
ohnehin hagelt es kritik an der
regierung zu spät ihre maßnahmen zu
wenige tests zu wenig schutzkleidung
andreas stamm berichtet das militär
packt mit an eine drive through
teststation im norden londons 100.000
corona test täglich hat die regierung
bis heute versprochen doch trotz
aushilfs klägern in tarnkleidung wird
das ziel verfehlt bevor man lockerungen
beschließt will man wissen wo neue
infektionsherde entstehen könnten die
bilden sich rund um infizierte wie man
weiß wo die sind in dem man testet
experten fordern nicht nur mehr test die
nachverfolgung von kontakten von corona
kranken per handy app müsse schnell
kommen und regelmäßige tests aller
mitarbeiter in krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen den jetzigen tsunami des
todes in altenheim hätten wir wohl
verhindern können wenn viel früher mehr
tests möglich gewesen wären
zu spät gehandelt versprechen gebrochen
kein plan zur lockerung der ausgangs
beschränkungen die die leidende
wirtschaft fordert schwere zeiten für
den premier vieles klingt nach
entschuldigung auf der ersten
pressekonferenz nach seiner schweren
corona erkrankung
ich will die logistischen probleme nicht
klein reden die wir hatten die richtige
schutzkleidung
den richtigen personen rechtzeitig in
krankenhäuser und pflegeheime zu
bekommen oder die rückschläge beim
ausweiten der test kapazitäten mit
champagner feierte der premier gestern
die geburt seines fünften kindes heute
hatte er nur hoffnung im gepäck und
nächste woche so johnson komme der plan
wie das virus besiegt und die wirtschaft
gerettet werden soll
über die entwicklung am arbeitsmarkt und
bei der kurzarbeit haben wir vorhin ja
bereits berichtet da gibt es aber auch
noch die drängende frage wie stehen die
chancen auf einen ausbildungsplatz
der chef der bundesagentur für arbeit
appelliert eindringlich an die betriebe
versprochene lehrstellen nicht zu
kündigen
die verunsicherung ist groß wie oliver
deuker berichtet elf auszubildende
beschäftigt hotel hase in laatzen bei
hannover wegen der korona krise ist das
restaurant bis auf ein bisschen außer
haus verkauf geschlossen dazu die
zimmervermietung drastisch eingebrochen
waren es wieder richtig losgeht
beeinflusst die frage ob zum sommer neu
azubis eingestellt werden wenn sich
morgen einer vorstellt dann könnte ich
dir nur sagen ich weiß nicht wie es wie
die öffnungszeiten sind wann wir wieder
altes geschäft haben wann wir wieder
hochfahren können
dann müsste ich jetzt nein sagen also
dann wahrscheinlich eher januar/februar
oder nächstes jahr auch bei hannover
konzerts ist das kerngeschäft
weggebrochen bis zu 400 veranstaltungen
im jahr organisiert die event-agentur
neue azubis sind hier derzeit kein thema
wohl wissen dass ihnen dann vielleicht
der nachwuchs fehlt dahingehend kann es
schon sein dass man dann in zwei jahren
in die erkenntnis hat dass man
vielleicht dieses jahr pause in dem man
eben vielleicht nicht ausbilden konnte
dass das empfiehlt und diese auch da
wären wir die krise vielleicht dann auch
erst zum späteren zeitpunkt erleben
leider
bundesweit bieten die arbeitgeber rund
39.000 ausbildungsplätze weniger an als
im vorjahr das könnte zu einer
verschärfung des fachkräftemangels
führen war die bundesagentur für arbeit
ein appell an die arbeitgeber in
deutschland ist möglichst bitte im
ausbildungsstellen zu besetzen damit wir
keinen ausbildungsjahrgang corona
kriegen denn es gibt ein leben nach der
krise
und dann brauchen wir junge menschen die
ausgebildet werden
denn auch nach der krise werden wir uns
im facharbeiter und sonstiges kümmern
müssen
statt betten machen oder rezeption im
hotel haase werden die vorhandenen
hotelfach azubis derzeit beim renovieren
eingespannt nicht ganz nach lehrplan
not macht erfinderisch auf familien
lastet im moment viel home office
homeschooling kinderbetreuung
all das muss unter einen hut gebracht
werden für kinder kann die situation zu
hause aber auch gefährlich werden
stichwort gewalt in den eigenen vier
wänden schulen und kitas als
frühwarnsystemen fallen zurzeit ja weg
stephanie heim kinder die geschlagen
oder angeschrieben werden eltern die
überfordert sind fälle für die
beratungsstellen des kinderschutzbundes
doch gerade jetzt wenn familien auf oft
engem raum bleiben müssen kommen
deutlich weniger als zuvor
alle fürchten dass das die ruhe vor dem
sturm ist weil jetzt die soziale
aufmerksamkeit zurückgegangen ist und
ist deswegen durch schulen
kindertagesstätten aber auch arztpraxen
weniger meldungen gibt
auch die familienministerin sieht das
problem keiner weiß was hinter den
geschlossenen türen passiert in
supermärkten will sie auf
hilfsmöglichkeiten bei häuslicher gewalt
gegen frauen aufmerksam machen
auch telefon hotlines für kinder und
jugendliche würden ausgebaut
wir haben dort auch zunehmend anrufe von
kindern und jugendlichen anonym und
kostenlos ist das möglich glaube dass es
ganz wichtig in dieser zeit das eben auf
die kinder und jugendhilfe weiter ihre
arbeit macht auch wenn das nicht im
persönlichen geht aber eben in der
telefon online video beratung
spielplätze oft noch zu kitas und
schulen öffnen erst vorsichtig in den
beratungsstellen melden sich zunehmend
nachbarn die streit und gebrüll hören
doch die beraterin sieht noch ein
anderes problem wenn man kinder auch gar
nicht mehr sieht obwohl man weiß da ist
eine familie mit kindern
wenn vielleicht vorhänge zugezogen sind
dass das können so hinweise darauf sein
dass familien wirklich sehr sehr
schlecht geht kinder haben ein recht auf
gewaltfreie erziehung auch wenn verstöße
derzeit wohl oft im verborgenen bleiben
in berlin sorgt eine wichtige personalie
für streit innerhalb der spd es geht um
den wehrbeauftragten des bundestags
bisher war das hans peter bartels von
der spd
und eigentlich hätte er noch eine zweite
amtszeit haben können
doch die spd fraktionsspitze schlägt
jetzt überraschend eva högl als
nachfolgerin vor
obwohl sie keine kompetenz in sachen
bundeswehr habe sagen kritiker der
wehrbeauftragte kümmert sich um die
belange der soldatinnen und soldaten
cornelia schiemenz berichtet unbequem
unabhängig und nah dran an den sorgen
der soldaten so hat hans peter bartels
seinen job als wehrbeauftragter
verstanden überraschend heißt es für ihn
nun wohl aus und vorbei posten räumen
hans peter bartels hat aus sicht der cdu
csu fraktion einen hervorragenden job
gemacht war anwalt der soldatinnen
soldaten hat auch gute
sicherheitspolitische anstöße gegeben es
ist entscheidung der spd dass er nicht
wieder nominiert worden ist und wir
mischen uns nicht in
entscheidungen unseres
koalitionspartners ein wir hätten ihn
wieder gewählt doch die eigenen leute
wollen nicht mehr warum darüber herrscht
in der fraktion eisiges schweigen
bartels selbst schreibt an alle
fraktionsmitglieder stellt fragen warum
ist dies heute eine politische stelle an
der die spd in dieser zeit einen
personalwechsel braucht welche
sozialdemokratischen binnen logik folgt
das fraktionschef rolf mützenich will
die berliner bundestagsabgeordnete eva
högl als neue wehrbeauftragte keine
begründung von ihm was sie für diesen
job qualifiziert welche vögel nicht zu
nahetreten dies mit sicherheit eine gute
innenpolitikerin hat aber was das thema
verteidigung und außen betrifft bis dato
überhaupt keine expertise und wir sind
einigermaßen überrascht bis entsetzt
dass man jemanden eine stelle setzt
hätte ich für soldatinnen soldaten von
hoher relevanz ist dass man dort jemand
hinsetzt der bis dato damit nichts zu
tun hatte nächste woche wird gewählt und
so ganz sicher scheint sich rolf
mützenich mit seinem vorschlag nicht so
seien vorsorglich bittet er seine
fraktion um gute präsenz um die absolute
mehrheit sicherzustellen
eine womöglich wegweisende juristische
einschätzung zum diesel skandal kommt
aus luxemburg abschalt einrichtungen in
dieselautos sind grundsätzlich
unzulässig stellt die generalanwältin
beim europäischen gerichtshof in ihrem
gutachten fest dies ist zwar noch kein
urteil aber meist folgt der ogh den
empfehlungen kommt das tatsächlich so
könnte das weitreichende folgen haben
in deutschland wären weitere millionen
autos illegal unterwegs und müssten
nachgebessert werden auch fahrzeuge die
bereits ein software-update haben
könnten erneut betroffen sein
der militärische arm der libanesischen
hisbollah steht schon seit jahren auf
der terrorliste der eu
heute nun hat innenminister seehofer
auch den politischen teil der
islamistischen vereinigung verboten sich
in deutschland zu betätigen
am morgen durchsuchte die polizei in
mehreren bundesländern moscheevereine
sie stehen im verdacht teil der terror
organisation zu sein die zur vernichtung
israels
ruft die hisbollah wird vor allem von
iran unterstützt und für zahlreiche
anschläge verantwortlich gemacht und wir
haben noch einen richtig runden
geburtstag tom moore ist 100 jahre alt
geworden
das ist der britische weltkriegsveteran
der millionen pfund den kampf gegen
korona gesammelt hat das land liebt ihn
dafür und beförderte ihn jetzt offiziell
vom captain zum kernel dazu noch einen
überflug über sein haus mit original
jagd pflege und mehr als 140000
geburtstagskarten gesungen wurde
natürlich auch
wechselhafte aussichten kommen gleich
von katja honnefer es gibt regen aber
zwischendurch auch mal sonne genauer
erklärt sie es ihnen gleich selber so
viel von uns schön dass sie dabei waren
um 5.10 gibt es das heute journal mit
christian sievers und einem gespräch mit
dem dgb chef und ab dem ersten mai
morgen freut sich barbara hahlweg auf
sie einen angenehmen abend und tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren in
lockerer folge ziehen die tiefs über uns
hinweg sie bringen immer wieder regen
mit und daher bleibt es bei uns auch
relativ kühl das ändert sich in den
nächsten tagen nicht heute nachziehen
erstmal regenwolken hier im osten ab
dann gibt es einen kurzen bereich eine
kurze regenpause bevor dann von westen
der nächste regen heran kommt und dieses
regenband liegt dann morgen früh so
zwischen der nordseeküste und im pfälzer
wald und zieht im laufe des tages weiter
ostwärts danach gibt es etliche regen
schauer und kurze gewitter
aber zwischendurch zeigt sich doch auch
immer mal ganz kurz die sonne und in den
gewittern da kann es durchaus auch mal
stürmische böen geben
der wind kommt aus südwestlichen
richtungen heute nacht sinken die
temperaturen werte zwischen 10 grad in
der lausitz und 4 grad an den alpen und
steigen morgen über tag auf 11 grad am
alpenrand und bis 19 grad hier südlich
von berlin eher wechselhaft geht es dann
auch am samstag weiter am sonntag wird
deutlich freundlicher im westen und am
montag steigen die temperaturen am
oberrhein schon wieder über 20 grad wenn
das wetter jetzt etwas wechselhaft wird
na ja wir haben ja gerade nicht so
wahnsinnig viel vor
schönen abend noch